The year is 2022. OpenAI just released
instruct GPT which is the first model
who can take instructions and actually
follow them really do what you wanted to
do. Hey, they have even called their
model instruct
GPT. So how come three and a half years
later in 2025 when they release GPT 4.1
they still have trouble to follow
instruction? And it's not just them,
right? Every language model has some
problems with following instructions.
And why is that? So, if you remember the
good old days of instruct GPT, this was
one of the examples that blew
everybody's mind, right? Explain the
moon landing to a six-year-old. We got
something nice and everybody went
bananas. And then with time, more and
more developers started to use language
models. And now the instruction looks
more something like this.
or this or this, right? And that's what
everybody's doing. Just taking all the
information, all the context, all the
constraints, all the requirements, just
put everything in one prompt and hope
for the
better. And really, even for simple
tasks such as instruction following, LM
alone are no longer enough. And this is
where AI agents come to play. And agents
don't just use prompting, they need
planning. I'm Ival. I work at AI21 Labs
where we developed our own language
models and also an agentic framework.
And I want to talk to you about
planning. So let's maybe start first
with what is an agent? There's a
philosophical debate. Everybody's
wondering. And the truth is as an
engineer myself, I don't care. Whatever
works, just make it work. Call it an
agent. Call it a workflow. call it
whatever. Hey, some people call LLM as a
router an agent where we have some sort
of a routing model that just takes any
query and directs it into a specialized
LLM. Is this an AI agent? Who cares? We
also have function calling, right? where
essentially we're providing the LLM a
list of external tools that it can use
and let it interact with other APIs with
the world Google search where this is
something that now a lot of people talk
about MCP where it standardized this and
everything MCP related is an agent again
doesn't matter as long as it works and
there's a lot of information about MCP
right now so we will not get into it and
maybe the most popular agent of it all
is react act to reason in an action
where this is a framework that can be
done with any language model in the
framework of thought then act upon that
thought and observe and so on and so on
every time the model wants to do some
sort of a step towards uh the solution
but this is something that happens each
step at a time and there is no look
ahead to the entire plan this is kind of
like part of a plan I know the situation
right now I know what the next step I
want to go to and so on and so
on. And what is planning that we're
talking about that every AI agent
essentially needs to do. So it's
figuring out the steps that you have to
take to reach your goal. And when do you
want to use it is when there is no
straightforward problems essentially
complex tasks and that it requires
parallelization and
explanability rather than react where
you can't really understand what
happened you can just see all the
thoughts that happened throughout but
you don't really know why you can talk
about forms based planners such as text
bl based as magentic one by Microsoft or
code-based planners by small agents uh
from hanging face.
What do you mean when I say dynamic
planning is that there is an option to
do replan and essentially it's not just
have one plan and go all the way in this
plan in the middle you can ask yourself
is this plan good or should I do
planning and go somewhere else and when
we talk about efficiency we want to put
smart execution into that essentially
every planner need an execution engine
because an execution engine can analyze
dependencies between steps
which enables par parallel execution and
can also have some sort of a trade-off
between speed and cost. For instance,
you can use branch prediction for faster
systems. Let's take a look of a
simplified version of AI21 mastro which
is a system that uses both a planner and
smart execution engine. So you can see
here the very simple case of instruction
following really we have a prompt which
is essentially some context and the task
and the requirements are all those h
shouldn't be more than 10 paragraphs the
tone should be formal all mentions of
our brand should be positive and so on
and so on. the thing that you usually
just shove in the prompt. Now they are
separated so it will be easier to
validate. And you can see that in every
step here we have some sort of a an
execution tree or execution graph if you
will where in every step the planner and
the execution engine chooses several
candidates and only continue to fix and
improve those who seem promising. And
really there are several techniques here
that you can use for any system such as
using best of n where essentially
instead of one generation we sample from
any LLM with high temperature several
generations or maybe use different LLMs.
We also ditch the candidates that do not
seem like they will be good and only
pursue the best candidate or candidates
based on predefined budget and also we
have some sort of validation. So
iterations and keep fixing and so on and
so on. Here it how it looks in something
where maybe a bit more complicated where
again we have the input the original
input of the system and then we have
those tracks where the execution engine
can say what is the expected cost the
expected latency latency and success
probability and the planner will choose
accordingly the right path to go. we're
at the end. We will have some sort of a
reduce where we will have a lot of uh
results and we want to take the best one
or combine all of them for a complete
answer to the query that we had in in
the beginning. And you can see that it
actually works, right? You can actually
see that for if val for instance, hey,
we get really high results for GPTO 40
or cloud sonet 3.5 or or 3 mini. We're
getting very very high results by just
improving them and using our planner and
smart execution engine. Also for
requirement satisfaction, which is a
data set that we build internally based
on customer data. Again you can see that
we improve upon just a single call for
LLMs and we are paying a little bit here
uh with right more runtime and more
money but we get higher
quality. So this is really the takeaways
here that LLMs alone are not always
enough even for what we call simple
tasks such as just instruction
following. I will always say start
simple and then use whatever work. So if
you can use SLMs use SLMs. If you can
just take a model and put some tools
into it, have at it, that's great. Use
React if you can. And if you really
need, if your task is so complex, you
have to use planning and execution
engine. This is where you should go and
explore. And I do invite you to join the
master weight list to check it out and
see if it works for you. Thank you.